when I open this envelope for gifted  nominees will engage their considerable  talents to convince us they're happy a  fifth nominee is taking home the Oscar  the nominees for Best Performance by an  actress in a supporting role are Holly  Hunter in the firm Anna Paquin the piano  Rosie Perez in fearless Winona Ryder the  age of innocence  Emma Thompson in the name of the Father  the best performance by an actress in a  supporting role the Oscar goes to Anna  Paquin  I think the Academy will be honoring  we'd be here today I'd thank Jane Jenn  and Hali for making this all possible  I'd like to thank Eddie Campbell pet  quick and convenient for taking such  good care of me during the making of the  film